okay for people who are joining this
livestream um long-awaited meeting about
the public packer repository um and
let's see make this a little bigger
alright so the concept is well who's
gonna describe the basic story is yeah
it's Bob gonna describe it somebody else
gonna describe it sure I can describe it
the basic idea is you know we have this
beckylyn system that's been around
forever and it's been sort of invisible
behind the scenes working perfectly
most of the time and doing great stuff
but we want to both expose it which todd
has sort of done already for the version
and we want to open it up so that it's
easier for people to put their own was
away now what is what has what has toad
already done I mean a little bit so
documenting your moving moving this
stuff that exists forever into a system
context and documenting it and doing
some some slight changes to the
functionality the API the symbol names
and with this so can I see that
documentation there that documentation
is does not exist yet written it isn't
we can't there's nothing to show you
have for the documentation we'll have to
have a meeting about that in the future
okay but so if I'm a private user so to
speak can I have my own Pacolet server
yes you can definitely do that you've
actually been able to do that for a long
time okay but now it's out of telling
how to do it it's possible let's go
through what is in a Pacolet where is I
mean is this about the Packer system or
is this about the record repository and
you know I mean if we if we talk about
tackle it's in general I mean that's
gonna easily just looks so much of this
meeting let's survey that for a second
okay um I'm just I'm just trying to
understand what you know it Pacolet it's
just it's a unit of rule from Wolfram
system functionality can contain almost
any kind of role from system resource
from dot m-files
to Wolfram libraries to front-end
stylesheets and powers
okay so snowman at the top level how I
specify Pacolet this is more relevant
than you think
okay oh right we've had discussed before
you don't really specify a part of the
top level you are you you you can ask
what's our installed on your system and
you find you you are given a pocket
object via you know the representation
of the packet in the Wolfram language is
a packet object expression and this is
something that you generally do not type
in by hand but or rather given it by
some function like Packers fine that's
the main but if I'm creating a packet
how do I do it if you're creating a
packet you you do not start by creating
a but Bob is going to show things later
on some ideas for I mean we can give
people tools that will a bit give them
start out with developing a packet that
will create how do you typically have a
directory okay a certain structure and
certain files within it good let's give
another them okay so in the function
repository you know we have this
essentially GUI for creating what
becomes a resource object that then goes
into the no resource system now in a
sense all the stuff that's in here gets
packaged up into that Association
correct right right okay so is the idea
to do something similar with packets
yeah that's towards the bottom of this
notebook if you if you run it my concept
my proposal for that is
so you add you have to run so that the
first four cells there aren't the dog
food so that via packet manager I've
actually deployed a resource system to
my cloud account and created a Pacolet
server oh geez okay I don't know why
that failed are you and this is 12:1 I
assume yep okay well if if the part of
the end fails then I can get ready to
show it on my screen well I assume it
will fail now why wouldn't it fell it
hasn't successfully got the resource
system client well it might only need
that packet resource 1 um so and then if
you if you go down to using a definition
notebook you can try doing those things
we'll see if it works
nope okay you want to show me on your
screen alright let me clear off some
stuff that I'd rather not put on a live
stream and I'll show you in a minute ok
let me just make some remarks I mean
what we want to get people a tool to it
says ok I'm gonna start packet you know
and to do that I need to directly
somewhere on either Proctor info file
and if we give people a tool that that
helps them create that and even manage
that going forward that's great but a
packet development process is usually
something that it's a long-term thing I
mean I I write peckers all the time and
we have hundreds of people making
packets within the company and they're
working in there I can use I can work
days or weeks at a time to produce
something you know it's not like you
just you know you don't understand
understand but somehow I want to take
back to them profile right and we can
definitely provide tools take one for
you and give you fields to fill out how
do you how do people make back that info
files right now
they write them by hand they're very
small they're very simple files they
write them by hand well but and how
would I say install a pallet from a
packet info file you isn't a mess info
file describes the ways in which the
packet extends the system it has issues
called extensions and all you do is
specify that you have a fun and
extension that's a way of telling that
you're that's a way to just tell the
packet manager that your packet has
funded resources so you your your
directory structure of your tackle
events will have a pallet file say in
the appropriate directory subdirectory
and that's all you do it doesn't you
just simply say in other words in your
packet info file it is kind of a quirk
that the file organization of our whole
system that I guess I had to invent in
like 1990 after things started getting
very messy is the source still the same
system we're using today and I guess
it's working ok so in other words even
what he likes me to show you it was 1996
and I remember because I was there what
did we have before that was it the I
mean I mean we had something before that
but it it got dramatically more modern
in 1996 and then it's kind of been more
or less in that form since then with a
few tweaks here and there fair enough
okay well I'm losing track of time
obviously yeah I think there may have
been a previous iteration of rearranger
a little earlier but ok Brian by the way
on our live stream makes the point that
I would make to um you know unknown
error is one of the most ridiculous and
useless things that you can ever print
out why does it say that
I those are probably some son of the
unknown there's my powder what's that
that's coming out of my coat okay
I mean it's terrible I mean it reminds
me I got to tell my story about using an
IBM mainframe in probably in 1977 where
you know it produces some message i eh 0
3 2 1 or something and they're these
giant paper manuals and i look through
these giant paper manuals and they've
got pages and pages of error messages
and i finally find the message that I
have and all it says is probable user
error well that's great scripture though
it means you did something wrong
I know I know I know I was just then no
question is what up what are all the
giant you know several linear feet of
paper that are the other error messages
things like you know a rat climbed into
the wiring or something I don't know
anyway no no I don't did this I know an
error is one of those things that's
really not supposed to happen
I kind of this falls through of course I
don't even it wasn't it's not like the
file we wouldn't unzip or it didn't have
the right content or there was an HTTP
error trying to download it all those
things are reported so I really don't
know what is going on here honestly
think that just the very phrase unknown
error is a red flag for people like me
who just like how could that possibly
happen any case okay I should probably
just not show it I never should just not
show the words unknown error I don't
think it's yeah accident so this is my
idea where basically the traditional
packet info file makes up the body of
this of this package notebook and then
there's all this stuff around the
outside that goes into resource
objecting it resource objectifying so is
the stuff you have at the top they're
real or is the stuff you have at the top
well it's mostly fake
but the idea would be nobody the UX is
intended to be real that's not so this
would pop open a notebook where you
would document the symbol and you can
see here this obviously would not be
just blade in the end form but the
notebook metadata will track these
things and it all sort of be held in
memory until you deploy it kind of like
the function resource if you deploy it
it'll build the directory structure as
needed for a minute let me let me try to
understand this so you're telling me I
mean most of this work is you know
people might be building things in
notebooks they might be building things
in an external IDE they're basically
having a directories worth of stuff that
they built right yes and if it's in the
proper layout then you don't necessarily
need a GUI you just say okay what should
be in that layer in other words if it's
scattered all over the place did the
ideas so a typical thing that I might
want to do is I've got a bunch of
definitions of random symbols and things
in notebooks I then want to put some
document you know put together some
documentation and you know I might want
to have some separate files one each for
documenting each of these various
symbols and so on how would I start to
do that right I mean so we can talk
about was everyone to ask people that
copy their code into package files or no
absolutely loads oh books dynamically
you ever do some sort of scraping and
dumping there's a one time offer no no
wait wait a sec whizzing that you know
when you build the packet for deployment
you can do whatever you want but you
can't ask people to take you know we got
to let people develop in notebooks if
they want to write an ID if they want to
but though by the way when you build the
Pacolet the the resulting thing might
not unpack with no book files in it
right oh yeah who cares they're never
gonna see that
the resulting Pacolet is pure
implementation all they'll see is but I
don't even understand when the packet
unpacks where does the documentation
attached
for example the documentation is just as
part of your packet
it's a documentation directory in your
packet directory that's what we get to
do is them what do we expect the hook
will be do we expect that as we have
done in the past that we will have kind
of a user area and the route guide page
where it will attach things or what now
no I mean that does work for browsing
industry but if you put a documentation
extension in your packet info file then
your and and you have you know the index
gets built and all that your Doc's just
can be found I mean you can't browse in
there's no links on there is a link from
the installed guide install packages
add-ons link on the roof it's just a
very obscure way of getting into your
packet Doc's but it does exist
you can browse in that way but typically
people do it by searching anyways right
so they'll type the name with some
function or the name of the package into
the search field let's just find it
let's give an example of the function
repository okay so you know there's a
public function repository where you can
you know submit your things they'll get
published there then everybody can find
it there's a website everybody you know
understands it right so you can also
privately deploy functions into your
cloud account that you know you can
reference using the resource system path
but other people but but for example
collecting a guide page of functions
that you have deployed is something we
don't yet have well at well organized
although hopefully we will very soon but
that's a typical thing that you're going
to want to do from one of these padlets
is the tippy-top you know the question
is what is the tippy-top of the
documentation for the Pacolet is it a
guide page if so where does the guide
page attach to the rest of the
right so I mean that I had my an idea
for well I guess that's for what the
tippy-top is I had this idea that we
would have a new type of page which
would be maybe sort of like a marketing
type page for the Pacolet that sort of
plays that what's it all about what is
that but yeah but how to get there from
the recap age I don't know an answer to
that question yeah I don't have an
answer to the Knitting problem but I do
think the top level page is a good idea
but in the in the function in the public
Pacolet repository concept we are
anticipating that every one of these
pages will be accessible to everybody
through the web right so the the thing
that you see when you go to the index
page for this packet on the web would be
generated from what you put in here and
if you don't put anything in here it'll
be something boring this generated from
this okay Ethan a lot of live stream is
asking can you can you press the create
documentation button oh yeah I mean I've
done that a couple of times it's not
it's it's a placeholder you know it's
just it's just making dummy notebooks I
imagine these will look something like
the function repository one at least for
the symbol case yes and then for the for
the guide page it'll look something like
our guide pages and this one they look
very much said to be story one or will
they look like the in product I I mean
you know look at a function I think we
don't think it'll be
what-you-see-is-what-you-get necessarily
I think the function repository one is a
very nice way to do symbol documentation
and I would advocate it right I mean I
think I think it has most of the
elements we need there right if I have a
code section now in this case right I
could have a code section I don't see
why I shouldn't have a code section if
it wants to I mean it might be a
convenient way you're saying that in
product documentation for symbols that
live in chocolate will look different
it's quite different from in product
for symbols that are not in backwards
well hopefully it won't be very
different I mean we're trying to merge
the look we're trying to make the tools
that documentation tools that we
currently have for the function
repository be the way that people can
create you know use a level creation of
essentially built-in documentation like
pages that this is fine with me because
the tools that we have for building real
impact Docs format are very complicated
and yes I know a lot of work that's do
we have anybody who uh who's
representing is andre here by any chance
no okay
but yes that's the whole point is we're
trying to make a lightweight version of
docu tools that can be used by anybody
that will create similar pages and i
think the right way to do that is to
start for symbol pages to start from the
function repository thing which is
pretty close to that well we need we can
I want the right pages
I'm not directly involved in that effort
but you should make sure that I under
the impression that the people working
on the lite version of the documentation
creation tools we're doing it you
starting with the code starting with the
same framework that is used for the in
product dogs and yes that's right if
we're gonna what's your point but I
don't I'm not exactly too sure what the
function repository page looks like for
a symbol or anybody that like you were
what are you talking about I mean just
go to the function apposite or that's a
page but go go to one okay there's the
source right
now there's no box of usage box here yes
there it is yes there is go to any page
go to the build page go to the build
page but Bob here's a publish here's a
publish page and you can borrow these
guys look it looks very much like I was
looking at the unbuilt page I thought
that was the build page well that's the
oh no this is the authoring environment
and it on the web it built into this
okay and I mean the gold is building
into notebooks very often we have until
for building him in the notebooks it's
if it's a bit prototype II but okay what
was done here this is a separate branch
from but we're not using cloud notebooks
here unfortunately and we should be and
we probably will in the future in which
case there'll be a single you know it
will be a single track to build both of
those but if you think how will this
look in product there will be a way to
do that anything that gives people the
easy ability to create Docs and some
approves format is great from great okay
so the one thing that's coming also
hopefully Bob is the guide page builder
right yeah
yeah we should we should review that
sometime soon okay the the thing because
I think we should have the exact same
approach that you had for building
function pages for building guide pages
I mean there's some complicated things
about how you specify you know this who
goes first thing about creating a
function repository entry which you can
then link to and so on right right yeah
a bunch of a bunch of things that are
all coming out at the same time right
listing each other right okay so let's
go back here so we've got the concept
that there are these pages that you can
build we've got standardized
documentation pages I think those
documentation pages should be able to
contain definitions if you choose to
work that way if your definitions are
simple you might just want to put them
on the documentation pages otherwise
there's some other kind of page that
okay if it's a notebook it is getting
harvested
but simply for its definitions in other
words there's a notebook it could have
all kinds of magnificent text and
beautiful things in it but the the
packet maker will simply harvest it for
its definitions like nobody evaluate
followed they dump safe yeah basically
um and and similarly so that the
different source files are WL files
which could have come from the package
editor in the front end or they could
have come from an external IDE or dot NB
files which will be harvested does that
make sense to people for the kernel
extension that is correct but you see
but you're suggesting that they're
deployed the packet after its created
not gonna have dot NB files for the code
that's these file there's an altering
all meaning yeah that is correct it
would be harvested just like it is for
the function repository that you
notebook is harvested and there's no
sign of the notebook after it's deployed
right with with posters to play button
and the submit button both of those have
been implied scraping or harvesting
whatever you want to call it and during
that process notebook files will be
rendered into their goods right okay so
let's talk about things other than the
kernel component right and I really
think it's important in somewhere here
to just literally see a list you can
have pallet what can you have you can
have pallets you can have this you can
have that you know you can put in
character sets you can do you can do all
kinds of things but we do we have a list
of those things somewhere there's a list
of X there's a list of extensions that
are where is it you can also it's just
in it's not in any documentation file
just in the car let me give you an
example let me give you notes oh that's
not good enough because we obviously
need to document that let's say you've
got a menu set up TR file okay that's
something you want to do you want to
change your menus which you can do with
a padlet correct I think so you wouldn't
do it with menu setup that TR if you
knew if you
knew what was good for you but okay how
would you do it so I mean you don't want
to rewrite the menus for all kinds of
reasons what you do potentially want to
do is to be able to add items to menus
so you're not rewriting the stuff is
there you're adding something new and
that's typically done via a front-end
and M file okay fine you have an
extension what I'm saying is you guys
need to come up with an inventory of
what things you could add to well so we
mean we can do that but you know if if
we make all of this you know so that
it's incredibly easy and you know and
someone's just kind of walked through
while the system is turning cranks for
them we can do that but then you know
it's gonna take a lot longer to get this
system okay okay listen listen there is
no way we're gonna be able to do this
unless we can tell people what things
you can extend even if the list is
incomplete even if the list gets added
to overtime anyway but even know I was
doing anything I mean their district or
some where's the list I get actually
right I did you want me to tell you what
it is
you mean verbal I did actually I did
actually write a lot of things are on it
roughly is it five at 25 it's about cat
okay so can you go through them just
just give me something what the colonel
there's a kernel extension okay that's
for some pause yep that's the code
there's a documentation extension yep
there's the front-end extension okay
you're gonna tell theirs that's cool but
go ahead that's for you know Palace
statutes things like that right well
it's not things like that let's have a
definite list palates stylesheets menu
extensions anything else well there's a
text whatever can go into their text
resources and system resources
directories in the front end I mean Todd
is the front end and that damn
considered part of the front end
extension or is it
something different that's something
different okay okay next up what else
there's a J link extension so you can
have Java code that is automatically
found okay as a library link extension
or you know for libraries and libraries
and then learn about key be found
there's there's a resource extension
which is kind of a generic way of
locating arbitrary resources within your
packet and here are terminologies
collided right now it's not it's not
related to the resource system okay
women
but but that is just you put a random
file in there which you might because
because for example let's imagine that
you wanted a file of sample data where
would you put that file of sample data
you know you want that awesome that
would be a good example for the resource
extension you could use that and you can
look it up by name and then there's a
wait wait wait wait wait hold on a
second hold on a second so what you're
saying is there's a random blob of
directories that this thing could
install somewhere in a in a user base
directory presumably basic place is that
correct but hold on no you have to
remember we just as before when you
install package it does not gather its
contents out in the system they all
remain in one place okay Packard manager
we've tells the system about those
places so for example if I say if I say
import and then something is that
automatically found because dollar path
has been extended to include the padlet
or what gala path is extended to include
the package if you have a path extension
in your packet right so the path
extension is another sense you can have
but basically allows you to find things
wrong but so if I was gonna if I put a
random file in my padlet that I want to
import okay or for example increasingly
there will be random video audio
databases all kinds of random things
that are just files that I just want to
install right but I need code that can
find those files reliably
is there a notion of a pack lit basis or
something that a piece of code so let's
imagine I've got this okay I put a piece
of video that it's in my packet right
and I have a function that's gonna bring
up this little thing that's a video of a
talking dinosaur giving help or
something talking paper clip giving help
whatever it is okay how do I have a
piece of code that referred resource
chocolate resource first argument the
name of the packet the second argument
is the name of the resource that's that
will a turn the full packet of it okay
excellent okay fine okay great so we've
got a way of referring to I don't think
that name needs can make it but but
something like that right that's alright
name can't make it I need to know now
that's that for name it's always been in
like this before you know if we want a
new name we can add it but we do have to
continues report then I understand but
you better so we better do a review of
all these names okay but that's a good
mechanism
okay so packet resource is something
that relative to the base wherever that
may be of that padlets files that gives
you a way to find something relative to
that base is that correct yes and it is
literally a file that second argument to
packet resource is a relative file path
is that correct no the second argument
is a name the actual location of where
that's okay by only be hierarchical okay
so let's imagine I've got ten thousand
things that I'm adding as packet
resources and I want them in a big
directory structure I want to refer to
them as if they're direct so I want to
actually process them as directories
let's say that I've got a bunch of I
don't know machine learning training
files or something can I do that and I
don't want to say every one on its own I
want to be able to think of them as a
hierarchical system as directories which
is presumably what they are yeah if you
want to name you know you could have
packet resource it points to that gives
us symbolic name to some directory you
know
stuff or something and and then your
code refers to that name as just a quick
resource over some chocolate column
mascot and the actual location of that
directory is no that's not what I'm
asking for I hope - I want file system
map to work across that directory right
let me okay so if your packet resource
names a directory then you your packet
resource call returns the full path for
that directory so that's the thing you
pass the filesystem map right okay fine
so so packet resource which is badly
named in my opinion because it should
basically say you know Pacolet file path
or some such other thing because what
it's going to return you just told me it
returns apart it returns it returns that
but that's what I think that's a
terrible name because the point the name
describes me it's very much it's a
symbolic lookup of something the actual
thing that you get when you call packet
resource it's controlled by the packet
input item I understand you then you
don't it's not a file page it returns a
file path but it doesn't take a file
path right no but what it's returning
it's not returning the goods it's
returning a pointer to the goods it's
returning a name of the file it returned
a full pack that's always fine fine fine
but it okay then it's like it should be
something like you know it is a okay we
have to we have to talk about this but
basically I'm a scammer that's perfect
I'm not sure that's the right name
either but I mean I I understand what
it's doing it's a sensible mechanism so
you name an object that you name
something that is either a file or a
directory if I'm understanding correctly
yeah this then returns the path to that
file or directory' the absolute path to
that file or directory so that then you
can do whatever you want with it okay
and that so basically the way I should
think about this is there a certain you
know there's certain elements and and
this reminds me a lot of what we're
doing in the cloud and I think we should
model this on that ok so there's certain
directories that are special directories
that have special meanings like the
directory that contains style sheets
that is accessible from your style sheet
system right so similarly in the cloud
there are things like and does somebody
who knows the new version of the cloud
deployment and directory structure can
they speak to this as anybody who knows
that the things like the publisher
memory okay so the whole point is that
there are higher level things like like
the directory that contains scheduled
tasks ok objects that represent
scheduled tasks the point is that those
may have a different interface to reach
them and they are a different kind of
blessed directory area separate from the
run-of-the-mill I'm just a cloud object
area do you get what I'm saying yeah ok
and what we've done in the cloud is to
distinguish the home directory from
these blessed directories so to speak
what makes sense and what we're saying
here with respect to packet installation
and the desktop is that again there are
these special directories that have
special significance for the desktop
system like they could install something
that affects the menus and there are
other ones that are just generic file
storage correct just just to be clear
the whole it directors that you're now
talking about all the directories that
have content for pockets are all being
decide okay where they are it doesn't
make any difference it doesn't make any
it's the same thing look the important
point is that there are pieces in that
file system where the file is just there
you know you put it wherever you feel
like putting it ok there are special
places in that pack lit file system that
have special significance for the system
because they rewrite the menus for
example am i making sense yes there are
a couple
couple of directories had like the front
end you know it's not a couple bunch of
directories that have you know it's the
library link one it's a bunch of other
one yeah there's a bunch of directories
that have special significance for the
system right it's the same thing in and
they have you know in the cloud it's the
same thing there's a directory that
contains your tasks for example
scheduled tasks now those scheduled
tasks in that particular case might work
even if they weren't in that directory
but there are special tools that the
cloud provides for managing those things
when they are in that directory and the
same thing here although as you say
these things are packaged up so that it
is localized to within that pack light
but the same idea applies that there are
system directories yeah well and their
system directories in another
fundamental sense which is that when you
have installed a Pacolet now and there
is a separate you know universe when
you're developing packets but when
you've installed a packet that's a
that's generally a read-only thing you
know it's not saying you're not going
back and writing to the guts of the
packet that's not an allowed operation
okay you might write other data but it
would go into another location not
inside the package fair enough and
that's the same is true with some of the
things in the cloud but my point I keep
on making is you've got to think about
these packets as you know that they're
delivering things which have special
significance for the system yes and most
of what the fact manager does is making
that work I know I know that I realize
that right admitting those things into
the system so the system knows about
those things you know setting up indices
for documentation doing this doing that
I get it so the point that I'm making is
from the point of view of this padlet
info file creation thing we've got to
distinguish what things are going you
know okay I've got a directory full of
random gunk okay some of that random
gunk is library link files some of it is
guide pages for documentation some of it
is random assets that I by the way asset
is a good name to use for this as an
alternative resource that's actually a
great idea I like that yeah um anyway
the it also suggests that they're not
writable um okay in any case all right
so you've got these things and you've
got to tell it where they are and as a
matter of developing these things what
will typically happen is that you'll
have a directory with these things in it
and maybe what we give people and maybe
you've already done this is a convention
for have this directory have these you
know subdirectories in it that mirror
essentially the the directory structure
that will exist in the packet itself and
then if you set things up with that
directory structure like you know
documentation slash whatever right if
you set things up that way they just
point the Pacolet you know creator to
that you know file system and say go do
your thing
alternatively I could give it a manifest
so have you done that no it's done in
the former way where you you are you
create the appropriate file layout and
the reason you do this is because you
are developing this package for awhile
and you have to run you I know so you
know you definitely don't have a
directory with a bunch of junk
scattering like a library file and
notebook you wouldn't be able to run
your code that's not right because what
you should do is to provide a function
that does whatever you do to package up
the Pacolet and run it right during
development you should have a function
that just does that without packaging it
up just says take all this stuff take
all these assets and make them live
right now in other words you do the part
of what the packet manager does that is
that knitting that you're talking about
but you don't need to package up those
are two separate things take all these
packaging packaging it up I mean if you
mean like creating a Dutch Packer file
that's definitely something you don't do
or need to do during the
development but it mean the workflow of
a developer is that you are going to be
you would need to create your files in
the layout that is the there is the
runtime layout and otherwise you're
having to go to a step okay that's fine
that's fine you want to run it that's
that's wonderful but how about the
missing so you're developing this packet
but you want to actually see what those
menus look like when they're rewrite how
do you do there's a function called
packet directory add that was one of the
functions that I talked with you about
this weekend package actually add that
just that just says look in this
directory for a packet and as soon as
you do that the nating is done okay fine
fine I'm not sure that's the right name
I don't think it is the right but and
one of the important is that it makes no
permanent changes it makes a session
change change it's kind of like
appending to the path or something so
just fine and why even you did approve
that name okay okay all right so let's
go back here all right what is this you
like to think this room is the same
Knoblauch you were sharing initially I
can give you the screen back you feel no
no no continue to share it right so how
the directory Adam is also going to
extend to resource objects a packet type
so right and this is a good idea here so
that that add yeah that takes a packet
that's represented by resource object or
just as a beckylyn object itself and as
it for the session packet install does
it permanently okay so let's let's now
zoom out so we've got some idea about
the padlet creation process okay and
roughly what that's going to look like
so it's either gonna be a function that
is just pointed at a directory and sold
just go do the deal with this right or
it's got something where you would
explicitly write the manifest in the way
that you're doing with that purple theme
grammar left um okay let's address a few
of the things on our live stream how
would you make a packet requires large
external things
Python libraries databases etc just just
fine you just put the things in there by
the way one exciting thing is that it
looks like we are going to be
successfully able to sandbox external
languages like Python so that it will be
possible even in the function repository
to have but not an ordinary sandbox it
but also will be able to include a
distribution so that you will be able to
transparently include code written well
in Java Python various other things and
have that just work and and through
library link C code and have that just
work in the function repository is that
a fair representation of reality yes
that's her
yeah that's an optimistic but you know
hopeful representation of reality but
let me just answer that person's
question about because the thinking is
that maybe there could be a Python
extension so I would just declare a
python extension in my Pacolet and that
would have some default root directory
or you know i could name the ruin and i
might throw some pi files or whatever
into that directory and then they could
be automatically found by external
evaluate and that that sort of thing is
feasible there's nothing on the table
right now to produce that and yet what
was the other example Python and
databases and databases right so the
same thing with you know you could have
some I mean we could provide a database
of extension that would have some
built-in logic for weaving things in the
data in your database directory into the
database system we don't have that yet
but all those things are feasible and
you could you can wire those things up
yourself you can come up with you make
up your own extension so a user could
make up a database extension and and
then search for that search for packets
without extension and load the resources
for example you know it kind of like a
plug-in system but ideally I mean the
plan is to produce for us to do more of
these built-in extension types that we
weed into the system automatically for
it right okay so another point on the on
the live stream here Ethan is pointing
out how to integrate with docker and
with containerization to me that is
something that is above the level of the
packages
you're talking about a docker container
for a kernel and all with its higher
knockers application level and I mean
we're here application is to find this
the really the Wolfram system as a whole
right that's a separate I mean a Wolfram
engine can install Becklund the question
is whether you could have a docker image
that is a Wolfram engine with a bunch of
pre-installed padlets
you know a threat for the case for the
case where you don't want to have to
download it efforts I don't see why not
kind of like it's very straightforward
you can okay just put all your packets
all the pendency one pretty mature
Darger's brian is commenting on multiple
versions of Pacolet yes absolutely those
can coexist it's a that is a
sophisticated agent they can coexist on
disk
you don't coexist running in your
session at the same time right within
one session you just have to have one
person of a Packard we don't have any
kind of you know within language
containerization you can have multiple
Packard's versions on your system loads
by different versions of Mathematica for
example okay dependencies and the whole
wonderful world of dependencies what can
we say about that we we have always
planned from the very beginning of the
packet manager to support dependency
that is not in 12.1 and so do we have a
brilliant solution I'm no I can't say
that we have one right now but I mean
and you know this is you know one of the
hardest problems of package management
generally but I am you know I'm in favor
of you know solving some of the problems
and then shipping those solutions rather
than waiting till we've solved every
problem yeah I think that's perfectly
reasonable um it's a question about
transmogrify and the whole way of
generating we are really going towards
using the
cloud notebooks as directly rather than
having to transmogrify anything to pure
HTML and those will get better and
better and they load very nicely right
now and they'll get even better and
basically you'll have both the
experience you know the good good things
about HTML and all of the SEO features
and all that kind of thing and you will
have the extra feature that all those
things that are special to cloud
notebooks like you know resizable
resizable images and all that kind of
thing will just work itself NPM does to
parents is by just stuffing a copy of
the dependency inside of itself I don't
understand that comment um so can I pack
like contain you know zip version of
another packet basically we're
definitely not doing that could be a
nightmare I mean the most level pockets
could Claire's and dependencies my
packet info file and then when I install
when the packets installed could simply
look at those dependencies and install
them as well I mean you know the real
problem here is that you know you have
versioning issues if you have one packet
depending on you know version X of
another packet and another one depending
on first and why and and and there's
just no reconciling the two then you
have to have some way to say okay well
it's you know when you know the first
packet using first necks you know that
it it's loaded into a namespace is
somehow completely independent from the
version Y if they use a stylesheet then
they have to have some way to say well
version X you know verse next stylesheet
verses a version Y style sheet that
otherwise has the same name the base
this process of sucking in definitions
that's what our full definitions
effectively does but that's I mean I
just outlined the case for that's not
gonna work which is style sheets no I
realize that I know those who start
living the same universe right but I'm
saying in the case
symbol definitions we were literally
just talking about this earlier today in
a different context what is happening is
when you do something in the function
repository for example it will suck in
the full definitions that it needs right
when you do a cloud deploy it will suck
in the definitions that it needs to make
that code work to the best ability
that's right and that is analogous what
that is something we are not proposing
to do here by default with padlets
because pack 'lets are what you what you
present in the pack that is what it's
delivered which is not the case in the
case of the function repository in the
case the function repository it is
storing is it not the full definitions
that's right that's right it's a
different paradigm here right so I mean
this dependency problem that people are
noting here the it's a hard problem in
every language no no I mean what we're
doing what we've done with the full full
definitions idea is that as a way of
saying freeze it I just want to take the
definitions that I have now and get
everything down to the sand so to speak
right by down to the sand I mean
everything above the system level
everything that was sort of added beyond
what is in the base system I want to you
know I want to explicitly store in this
package that I'm building and that's
what we're doing in several places and
it's worked surprisingly well I think
that this is a different model but I
think it would be good to merge those
two models so that one could do both of
these things and so one could say
somehow when one builds the Pacolet oh
by the way i when i build up the dot
Pacolet file suck in the full
definitions that are needed I don't see
why we shouldn't offer that alternative
you know this is related to something
else that we discussed which is the idea
of having namespace aliases yeah why is
that relevant well so you
you might for example it I mean if at
least for the Wolfram language issue the
if you really need the deal with two
versions of the code then you could you
know bring each of those versions and
independently using different aliases
right I understand that's interesting
that's interesting I mean probably would
be possible to prefix have an automatic
prefixing of contexts of some kind or an
automatic context mapping of some kind
okay anyway that's a and it wouldn't and
the rest of the code wouldn't know the
difference it's it's not unlike the
research function blob right which has
its but which by the way I would like to
complain about a bit because I've been
seeing way too many error messages that
contain those weird you know resource
function dollar whatever they are things
no words
anytime I'm seeing you need to make it
so the print form of those things
everywhere is something more civilized
am I making sense yes I understand yeah
right that's a separate thing to look at
okay what we're unfortunately running
out of time but but I'd like to Ethan is
commenting that the official
documentation is not yet cloud notebooks
you are absolutely correct we're just we
haven't been ready to do that eventually
we will probably do that um but I think
we're trying to build a more modern
stack for the the padlet system and so
on um would it be possible to create a
style sheet gallery or browser in a
packet it's another question here so I
mean yeah but you see the main issue
yeah the main issue is this okay is it's
the Knitting and you were bringing this
up Bob in the context of okay where do
we put this documentation well I
actually don't think that's that
difficult of a problem I mean in the
sense that I mean if we're just willing
to
Gate you know kind of olive the Don
Wolfram and we've done this historically
there used to be maybe there still is
there used to be a I always thought too
small of a hook like at the bottom of I
know that's the point John because let
me let me tell you about hook sizes here
nowhere yes yes yes
yeah let's talk about hook sizes right
to some people they want the packets
they've installed let's say that they're
working on some project you know they're
gonna open this padlet every day that's
the main thing they want to see when
they start the documentation is they're
packed like big in you know big letters
at the top right somebody else has
installed oh yeah I'm gonna put in a few
packets they're useful because they come
from other people blah blah blah do I
want to see them as a great big banner
ad at the top absolutely not well okay
so to be clear first of all I'm talking
about you know imagine one tile you know
which is you know I'm a friend of route
guide page one tile which is you know
user installed let's find a better name
but you know the you know I mean if you
want something that more prominently
goes to a guide page I mean maybe the
problem is you know that we don't have
good John I don't think this is right I
think there is no way of winning this
one that is what we've got here okay so
let's take this page and let's say we're
gonna add you know some user keep in
mind that search for work - I know I
know but but you know like like I have a
personal home page that has things I use
so for example recently I wanted a guide
page for Pat for function or private
function repository functions of mine
okay
how do I actually deal with that well
what I actually do is I add it to my
personal start you know my personal home
page which is what my web browser starts
okay it's
what you're asking for is fine
functionality but it doesn't have
anything to do with packets well it does
because no no no it doesn't because you
might you might want your personal page
to point to all kinds of stuff that's in
the system that you deeply care about I
understand I understand that but what
I'm saying is the pack 'let the the main
operation of the pack light is it is its
own encapsulated thing but it wants to
stick its neck out stick its hand out
and place some some marker to itself put
a flag in the sense of a flappy thing in
the wind type thing a flag you know
somewhere in the system like it wants to
put that flag by adding its its menu
items it wants to put that flag by
adding itself to the route guide mage it
wants to do a bunch of these things
right so under the control of the pack
light it needs to reach its arm out and
stick a flag somewhere else in the
system and so now we can ask ourselves I
have a couple of things so that where
does the flag go so we can say for every
elements of the system like the route
guide page we can provide a certain flag
enclosure a certain place where packets
can put their Flags that's one possible
model another thing we could do is we
could say free-for-all you know we we
try and well we wouldn't have to label
because you know how do you reference
different part let's imagine you wanted
to stick something at the top of the
route guide page how on earth would you
do that I would much prefer we didn't
try because when we do we lock ourselves
in hard to what I know I know how you
know I understand that so what you want
to do is you want the you know the the
reservation the enclosure for user flags
you want somewhere on this page you want
to use a flag reservation right and we
actually have this right now but it's
very obscure it's not even on your
screen right now it's add-ons and
packages there at the bottom right okay
fine so we have an enclosure we don't
think it's a big enough enclosure
it doesn't have I don't think it is okay
fair enough but but but okay so it could
not be smaller okay approach number one
is I don't know what happens when he go
there it's very old-fashioned looking
thing and it's in 12.1 way because those
are things which have like stopped
working to install but they've stopped
working because they don't they just
don't work in modern versions anymore
it would be my cats documentation there
you go
I mean it'll be nice to get this right
but yeah I I'm developed well from
language all day every day I go to the
route guide page once a month and I
search the search documentation five
times an hour so getting a search right
is I think ridiculously more well I go
to the route guide page a fair amount
even though I think I know roughly how
the system way wishing to survey the
live stream to see how often people go
there okay yeah people have won scones I
mean it pops up when I want to get to
the search dialog but I never browse
into the route guide page I do yeah but
anyway the the but okay nevertheless
there has to be a discovery interface so
search is one discovery interface right
there there has to be other discovery
interfaces to these things by the time
you're adding menu items you've got
another discovery interface right adding
a menu item is a discovery interface now
for example is that a walled enclosure
of menu items or could is it
free-for-all could I say I want to put a
new item at the top of the help menu
probably not probably you want an
enclosure a reservation into which the
the packet can write stuff I personally
think we should have these enclosures
probably but I think that there is a an
issue because I think that one person's
enclosure may be oh you know in other
words one of the great things about the
system
is that in principle you can you know
change what Plus does now nobody ever
does except for those people who in some
obscure corner want this thing that
really overwrites plus and does
something completely different and the
fact that they can do that and have it
not you know of it not blare at them you
know you know you know you're using or
the fact that you know we have the
convention of lowercase and uppercase
function names that's a convenient thing
but you know a user can perfectly well
as I do all the time you know name a
function with something that sort of a a
fake built-in function but the issue is
by the time you've made everything every
flag placement a second class location
um the you know some people won't like
that they so anyway that that's that's
one of the so Ethernet suggesting
discovery should be like the atom well
and and this is something that we
haven't talked about here I don't think
we have a design for but is certainly on
our radar which is that you should be
able to you know have a decent interface
for not only for you know installing
these things but interrogating which you
have installed right but but I'm saying
somewhere I mean there's sort of the
okay like for example okay this this my
personal route guide pay my personal
sort of home page with links to you know
in right now to this guide page of
function repository functions right now
obviously I just made these functions
but I still I'm going to that page many
times a day it's a useful thing to go to
and how do I get to that page well it's
convenient because I just go to a
browser I say start a new window I click
one link and I'm there so similarly we
need to provide something like that for
people to get to things that they have
created
but we don't know how prominent well
anyway that's that's one so you know I
mean if you can interrogate installed
you know installed packets then surely
one of the things you can interrogate
you know is how is is where they're
where the route guide pages for each
packet is assuming they have one sure
absolutely
yeah I mean the issue is if you look at
what I have for example so I have in my
add-ons and packages I have a bunch of
stuff that I probably installed more
than a decade ago that you know
including some really random things you
know service connection for nuance I
have no idea where that even works
anymore
I think by the pink box I'd say perhaps
not corporate analysis utilities okay
well that's interesting but I you know I
have no idea what that is okay that's
probably made you know a really long
time ago probably ten years ago you know
it's magnificent if it still works but I
do not want to see those on my route
guide page every day well and I'm not
suggesting you should see these on your
route guide page I mean you know you
know the installed add-ons concept while
it's you know not very pretty or you
know kind of well done right now I think
the concept isn't broken there's a tile
that you then go to that then has those
things in it yes and perhaps what you
could do who as an end-user maybe you
could rewrite I don't know I don't know
what you could do because the problem is
that if you rewrite that page the hook
that a packet you know puts if it wants
to put up a new flag you know like like
you know when New Zealand tried to
change its flag or whatever you know it
wants to put up a new flag it's it has
to be able to reach in and put up that
flag and if you just maybe it doesn't it
doesn't work that way it doesn't reach
you
the packet doesn't reach in and put a
flag somewhere the system asks all the
tack lists what do you have for me and
and so that would still work right I
mean that it wouldn't break if we change
the format of the or you know change
something dramatic about this page the
system looks for all packets and the
docs they provide and makes links to
them the packets themselves don't have
to know anything about what the
look like I mean they're not annoying
about this page they just provide
information via a function okay we got
to wrap this meeting in a minute but I
think one other big area that I think
you guys wanted to talk about was the
actual packet server right I mean the
concept that what you've defined here is
the way you can send somebody a dot
packet file and they can do all these
things but the issue is we want to
provide a public padlet server where
people can Lodge the dot packet file on
the server and then other people can
simply refer to that file from the
server is that correct
Yeah right I mean the demo at the top of
this notebook on the right the second
example are filling the URL in there is
a package server in a resource system
that we're in this one here yeah yeah
that's published yeah Bob it's it's
Bob's because it in when this is live
that up that Bob's of the resource
system okay so so this is very analogous
to what happens with the function
repository that is you can publish it
privately in your own cloud account and
it is a packet and the packet somebody
who has a copy of the system can ingest
that packet from that private padlet
location or yeah that would be the goal
but this is it's this isn't showing that
really this is showing from the
published repository it's just be able
to do that just like it's a very nice
mechanism for both the the function
system and you know because somebody
might want it to be in their private
account with all kinds of permissions
and so on or they can push it to the
public padlet pack the repository right
great oh great and the concept was well
what's up showing here is that is even
though he's just this website he's got
in his climate town is sort of intended
to be a representation of the real
public repository this is how I work
this is effectively a private PAC
website he's running out of his own
cloud account and under still there
exhilarate files I got it so the
public Pacolet repository right our
concept is that anybody can put stuff
there right
any presumably has to be registered user
can put stuff there yeah so I mean I
think you know it's really key that it
has you know it cannot be anonymous I
mean you know we can we can talk about
you know how your wolfram ID corresponds
to you know an identity that might be is
it just a user name and user name fine
or you know something else but it has to
be tied to a wolf might be in good
standing right right we have this
publisher system that Turner back in the
resource system that might be the right
thing for this so that multiple wolfram
IDs could use the same account that's
not something you know that I mean it's
come up in a you know this stuff that
we're doing with making our sort of you
know this this web page that we'd be
making website we'd be making that
there's been a whole can of worms
associated with having a central name
for the user access by multiple people
but yes ok fine the publisher ID
publisher ID system might solve that so
yet I mean names facing is of the
Pacolet is a whole conversation and then
name spacing of symbols conversation so
okay but the point is that the Pacolet
will have on the public Pacolet
repository the Pacolet will have a a
directory that depends on the username
presumably how does it work and I should
know this I mean in in like github you
just register a name and then that
becomes the directory in github that
your packages live under right right and
so presumably there are two components
you have a username or there might be a
team name which is a collaborative thing
and then you have the repository name
and you're any given repository is you
know it's combination of those two
things you know so there are no name
collisions because
you know because if someone else can
make the same name but it's under their
username or their team name right okay
so so then but then in terms of
versioning and all that kind of thing
the the public packet repository people
can make you know can do all kinds of
things with wild abandon they can make
and by the way they can perfectly well
if they want to put their packet on
github they can perfectly well do that
right yeah yeah well yeah and and and
you know some packets will you know the
the source form in some cases will look
different than what's actually being
deployed is so for example you may have
a library link and you know we're not
you know you're not gonna deploy the the
source code for that library link
probably there's no need to in a packet
but you would want to make it available
you know on a github repo if you want to
be open source right well but there's
nothing wrong with your site Eero
whatever could be pointing to github is
that correct moment that doesn't work
well Packard site is not it is the
Packer site is is a server with some bit
of logic associate with it right so you
it's not just a you don't you know the
packet manager would request to pack
that it was requested by name it doesn't
requested by a URL right so it doesn't
you know a means to work it well but
maybe we need a layer inside the client
that translates to that well and also I
I think that you know I mean you you
can't have deployed pack lists that come
directly from git repositories you can
have you know Pacolet a directory style
stuff that comes from from a git
repository but you know otherwise you
would have to have a different version
number for every single commit in the
git repository that going particularly
well well so you know III have something
that represents a pact 'let's in a git
repository and then I make a tweak to it
you know that that tweak is now a
different version you know if you are
considering it as coming directly from
the get source and that's you know
that's generally not what we've done
what we've done instead is you know we
have the open source in the git
repository but then we have released
packets and dot packet files that you
can download from github okay fine
fair enough but I mean that's still URL
so then your repo there would have a dot
Pacolet file that was built from other
files in the repository PO that are
correct yeah and if you like open the
next section that or via resource object
greece or subject can provide this in
language layer in between where it
doesn't have the required mapping of
name to file location rebecca cited if
you had a github repo and it basically
had a resource object to play to it like
it would be in a cloud it could point to
a packet file anywhere um someone's
pointing out that on github you can
obviously refer to the release version
yeah yeah yeah that's that's what we're
doing if you look at get like for
example you know or their various other
pack was to you know you'll see that
sort of thing okay yeah I mean basically
you you know you lay down a tag with a
version number and then you upload
binaries which correspond to the built
version of that you know those tag
sources okay in our case you're
uploading a click files right right okay
well we got a bunch of other things to
look at this would be clear you did
another meeting but but at some point
Todd we need a meeting to go over the
Pacolet documentation right about that
okay oh I'm around although I'm busily
working on something next few days so if
you happen to be but it will be after
you next week okay all right well I
think we should wrap this up and we
should continue I mean after we've done
the padlet design is there anything
that's holding anybody up here that we
make any decisions we need to make not
particularly okay um fine I mean there
are a lot of decisions we need to make
but well there are a lot here that the
go into the yeah everyone's in the
pre-flight and all that sort of stuff
yeah
that needs to be figured out yes there
are a lot of detailed issues but okay
looking good all right thanks guys
thanks to folks on the live stream um
Thanksgiving everybody
oh if we don't talk before then well I
I'm off tomorrow so okay well good